it's the double date that dreams are
made of nicki minaj and her hubby
kenneth petty rihanna and her beau asap
rocky i'm really really excited on
monday nikki shared this group shot to
instagram that's the rapper and her man
holding on to their baby boy while asap
and riri cozy up on the couch next to
the proud parents the caption hashtag
rockinria hashtag queenree hashtag
caribbean girls r unit love her down yes
in another post the grammy winner shared
this clip with rihanna blowing kisses at
the camera
caribbean things and i'm fine and in
this video rihanna's niece majesty gives
a shout out to nikki's fans the barbs
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the barbs wanted to say that they
thought you was cute and you want to say
anything to the barbs
hi
you love them yeah
tell them
i love you
nikki and rihanna haven't released a
song together since collaborating on the
2011 track fly which appeared on nikki's
hit album pink friday
[Applause]
[Music]
and the whole get-together had fans
tweeting that they hope new music is
coming from the pair dot dot dot to be
continued nikki and riri made headlines
back in may when they started following
each other on instagram leading fans to
speculate they had something cooking
that same month the rapper surprised
fans announcing that her beam me up
scotty mixtape would be available on
streaming platforms for the first time
ever meanwhile rihanna hasn't released a
new solo single since her album anti
came out in 2016. the singer also hasn't
been featured on a track since 2017 when
she appeared on future selfish dj
khalid's wild thoughts and kendrick
lamar's loyalty
[Music]
rihanna has been working with her man
though in july the power couple was
spotted looking all kinds of loved up in
the bronx enjoying a multi-day shoot for
the 32 year old rapper's new music video
a source at the time told et quote they
are so madly in love they barely leave
each other's side asap is so grateful
for rihanna she's his biggest
cheerleader and he doesn't take her for
granted and last july before they took
their love public riri featured rocky in
her fenty skin campaign to me in
in the industry he's one of the guys
that like everybody loves their skin i
mean i've always wanted to know like how
the heck do you have better skin like
half these girls i mean like what what
do you do and when it recently spoke to
the rapper about his documentary
stockholm syndrome he opened up about
having his superstar girlfriend support
i'm honestly truly blessed bro you know